are we about to get a very exciting
Babylon 5 announcement and has JMS
already hinted at it welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so on this channel I've talked a couple
of times now about how Babylon 5 was
going to get a reboot a reimagining well
now JMS the writer J Michael cisinski
actually announced this just over a year
ago the plan was to put the series on
the CW but then the CW got sold next
star bought it and a big proponent of
the Babylon 5 project who was the CEO at
the time left
um pedowitz I think was his name but I
might be wrong but anyway so what's
happening now well thanks to one of my
friends over at The Babylon 5 gray 17
podcast Scott who does follow JMS on
patreon I got a message saying that
actually JMS has just dropped an
interesting message he basically said
I've just had a very interesting phone
call from Warner Brothers
so I got onto the phone to a couple of
close sources that I have that work in
around the industry now they've been
sort of whispering to me for a little
while that there's been internal
conversations at Warner Brothers about
Babylon 5. so I actually told you a year
ago Warner Brothers would prefer Babylon
5 to go onto HBO Max not the CW they
think it would just be a better fit for
the streaming service rather than the CW
Network
since nextar took over the CW they've
been spending far more of their
investment on more family-friendly
television and moving away from things
like the DC
um I mean they just spent a crapload of
Money Getting the golf for the CW
Network so that tells you the sort of
demographic they're now aiming for so it
seemed even more likely that HBO Max
would end up being the target for a new
Babylon 5 reboot the problem being
though that the CW actually has first
dibs contractually they have the option
to take Babylon 5 first so I got onto
the phone I asked if there'd been any
changes and one source came back to me
and I have to admit this is going to be
very much in the rumor category they are
not 100 certain about this but they've
said they have heard a rumor that in the
last week or two the CW had actually
declined its option to Babylon 5
following Warner Brothers asking
repeatedly
that then triggered a bunch of internal
conversations for them trying to decide
what they wanted to do what sort of
money they would want to pay for a
project like the Babylon 5 reimagining
and what's the time scale they'd be
looking at that then caused them to
trigger a conversation with JMS the
phone call he may have received so the
phone call wouldn't have not have been
to phone him to say it's greenlit let's
crack on according to my source it's
more likely that the phone call was to
say we would love you to come in to have
a conversation we want to go through
what we're thinking we want to know what
you're thinking and then from there we
want to put a plan together now there's
going to be a long way to go until we
actually get an official announcement I
think but by that I think potentially
weeks is possible there needs to be
conversations about things like the plan
of budget again the time frame what sort
of hours they would want because again I
don't think this will be a 2 22 24
episode season like maybe the CW would
have ordered I think it's more likely
and the sources said to me that at most
we're going to get probably a 10 hours
first season but my source thinks it's
more likely that HBO Max would order a
mini series so basically what he said to
me here is that think about like how
Battlestar Galactic agar rebooted all
those years ago now for the Ronald D
Moore version we got the mini series
first that told that initial big story
and then off the popularity of that we
got the series now it's a slightly
different way of basically doing movie
than Series in this way you get sort of
like a straight to HBO Max miniseries
movie that will then lead into a new
series now I actually think that's quite
interesting because it could be quite a
safe way for HBO Max to do this I
actually do think the Babylon 5 project
is risky now I actually trust JMS I
think he's one of the best writers out
there I do follow him on Twitter and to
be honest his tweets crack me up every
single Pig in time they're so funny
um he is a bit of a genius but Babylon 5
is
quite a difficult Sci-Fi show it's very
popular but it is very quite Niche it's
quite dark in places and I think it it
very much was set in its time
reimagining it has never been done
before particularly when you think about
the actual showrunner doing it I just
think about there are so many ways this
show could go wrong if the casting is
even slightly wrong and slightly out and
people don't like some of the actors
that end up in the big starring roles
like jakar or Sheridan then I can see
people turning against it quite quickly
I also think unfortunately with the hate
clicking social media where we do things
nowadays that it will get a lot of
negative publicity into the run-up I
think a lot of that will be tempered by
the fact that JMS will actually be in
charge and write in the series
but if you look at a lot of the crap
that went around about Quantum Leap
before that got rebooted it was vile and
very negative and actually the show's
pretty good so none of it was warranted
but it still happened and unfortunately
I think there is a big threat of that
again
so
we may get a Babylon 5 reimagining and
we may get an announcement really soon
that program may not be the full series
24 episodes that we maybe want
but 10 12 episodes on HBO Max where
really
if you also think about it JMS will not
have any handcuffs he will not have any
restrictions on what he can do with the
show on HBO Max it can pretty much do
whatever he wants on the CW the family
friendly CW
they might put some restrictions on sort
of like the age rating of the TV show so
that could be an issue for me I don't
really want a soft family-friendly
version of Babylon 5 I would like the
JMS version of Babylon 5 and I just
think HBO might be a more sensible
location for that finally if you compare
Babylon 5 to Star Trek for a second
Babylon 5 was always darker always more
real you know the overriding story and
the overarching actual moral of the
story of Babylon 5 was that change is
always possible that change happens and
that sometimes you have to fight to get
that change and that change can hurt but
in the end it's necessary
Star Trek had a different moral to the
story Star Trek was kind of more like
what we can achieve if we all keep going
in that right direction that kindness
and love and understanding will
eventually beat all the anger and the
hate that most of us seem to carry
around in our hearts
Star Trek was the glossed over version
of the future Babylon 5 was always a
more realistic more real version of the
future Awards and all version and I
always really love that
but a modern version of that story is
going to have to be darker again I think
than Babylon 5 or it'll miss the Target
because we have so much television since
B5 that is much darker much grittier
much more warts and all for Babylon 5 to
succeed JMS has got to be given the
freedom to do what he wants to tell the
story but he's also got to make sure
that he actually tells a story that
people are still going to be interested
in today
and that is easier on HBO Max than it is
on the CW
but guys get into the comments tell me
what you think about this potential news
and I'm going to say again rumor but it
really does look like B5 is about to get
announced
weeks hopefully and I'm absolutely
certain JMS will tell us first on
patreon or his Twitter account
I will try and get you the news as
quickly as I possibly can as well though
but get into the comments tell me what
you think is this something that's
exciting a reimagining not a reboot is
that a problem of concern for you or
actually you know
is it just something we just want to see
what JMS comes up with basically because
I just think he's one of the best
writers out there and I'm really excited
to see what he comes up with I'll get in
the comments tell me exactly what you're
thinking if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and it really helps us out
also if you want to join us on patreon
you get to see most of our videos before
everybody else on YouTube and without
the adverts just for a small fee each
month that really supports the channel
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]